liam magnus with the white pieces in the
first
rapid game
no surprise
not pawn to f3 this time it's knight to
f3 the retti opening he mouse slipped
he meant to move the pawn there but he
forgot he just moved the knight there
instead
one of my favorite openings actually
just a very flexible bringing out of the
night now white has a selection of
choices which pawn to push
and talking about mouselip a lot of
people actually thought that magnus's
one f3 yesterday was actually a mouse
lip he actually intended to play this
night move and somehow by some
some serious mouse slip exactly you know
well you can kind of click on the square
right and then maybe
accidentally you know use your pawn and
then whoa mistake but no magnus had it
all planned out yeah we have seen mouse
slips throughout the tour especially
last season actually
here we do see magnus just choosing his
music i think the board is not up right
now so we have seen mouse slips in the
past but magnus he's so experienced
these days with the mouse he plays so
much online chess it's unlikely that
we'll see that again so okay just
pushing the pawn in front of his king
there very flexible um this is still
very well known stuff and now after
black develops his night white needs to
start challenging for the center i'm
expecting white seaporn to push forward
here this is a bit i mean e3 is not the
most normal move i know magnus had
actually prepared one e3 for one of the
olympiads i think is that right as his
main opening but
pretty i mean this now is going to a
more well-known position exactly and uh
one thing i've done in the past is
studied magnus carson's opening studied
his games and just looking on an opening
tree that you can create by having that
pool of information he's played pretty
much every first move there is so no
matter what move he starts with first he
often knows how to transpose back into
more
mainline waters and this is again
this has gone back into something more
well known black wants to castle the
king away very quickly magnus meanwhile
going for maybe an alternative strategy
pushing the b pawn there's not one b3
it's uh but it's the same idea white
dark squad bishop is going to fee and
keto itself there we go onto the longest
possible diagonal maybe hinting at a
kingside attack later on the bishop
poised on the same diagonal pointing
towards the black king but black does
try to open up the center and at least
fight for those central squares so there
are there are eight ten possible opening
moves correct twenty
one two how's it twenty so there's eight
pawns each one of them can make two
different squares
of course
but how many seconds
and when we come to move three right
it's like
insane amounts of possibilities yeah i
don't even know the number by the end of
black's first move there's 400 different
possible positions
white has 20 options black has 20
options so 20 times 20 400 and that's
after one move imagine by move two move
three it's
uh like in the hundred and thousands
millions probably actually almost
infinite yeah i think i think there's
actually some mathematical formula uh
that someone uh you know found so we can
probably that's a good question for the
audience i think i mean uh is there's
that legend isn't there how chess was
invented and uh this person invented
chess and the king said you can have
anything you want in the world and he
said well i want one grain of rice but
that grain to be doubled for every
square of the chess board and obviously
the king run out of rice who fought
that's easy i'll just give him you know
what's that bit of rice but he'd run out
of rice and he's like i can't do it so
that was sort of the
one of the legends around the original
chess
yeah what is magnus up to here it looks
like he's just resting his eyes it's his
opponent's move
but
it does definitely looks like
something's up with the world champion
yeah power nap time it's not a good time
to have a power nap though power naps
are awesome actually they give you not
during the games
yeah no but i mean you can actually um
have a power nap in like 45 seconds and
it will give you really yeah it will
give you a boost for one hour is that so
yeah 45 seconds yeah
because i used to do it all the time
because at some stage in my life you
know i suffered from this illness which
really made me tired and i would i was
having power naps all the time just to
kind of play chess
really oh that's interesting you have to
set an alarm though normally to try and
wake up and magnus doesn't have that
luxury okay meanwhile we do see a trade
of a set of pawns in the center
both sides just with very solid
positions here i think magnus will be
happy with the outcome of this opening
just because there's not too much action
it's the type of position where you can
just close your eyes for a minute or two
um there's no direct attack but it's
magnus's move now and is he aware
this is very strange
is magnus carlsen asleep no i i think
he's recording he must be recalling some
variation that he's looked at i say that
and i'm like hang on a minute
i'm not sure he can't he can't have just
fallen asleep at the board i mean uh
uh it's been like that for
a few minutes so we can't give him a
shove look at the breathing
his hand okay the breathing does show
sorry his hand is on the mouse though do
you sleep with the hand rested like that
well magnus would oh yeah most natural
position he couldn't have just walked in
and fallen asleep but if you're really
tired it's actually possible
did you see he had that you know when
you wake up yeah you have that he was
asleep and when you get older you tend
to fall asleep doing things like you'll
be there with your mobile phone and then
you know the other feeling when you're
your head dips
on an airplane or you could have slipped
with the mouse couldn't he and just put
his piece somewhere if he's not careful
but he's back to sleep again and he
hasn't made a move he hasn't made it
he's taking and i mean okay so clock's
ticking now for a minute and a half is
this a moment to take a pause
not really i mean there's
maybe two sensible moves i can come up
with here one is the most simple
castling the white king to safety which
he did eventually play another one was
maybe developing the white queen but
okay he castled and now he has perked up
um avoiding now a night trade that's
quite an instructive move you don't want
to trade off pieces when you have extra
space here it's
i mean it's very symmetrical but white
has a tiny bit more central control
slightly better uh bishops here
but uh okay magnus i wonder what the
rule is
if someone falls asleep in a tournament
i i don't think you're allowed to wake
them up because it's outside
interference i actually had this once at
all my friend uh fell asleep um in
ireland and i sort of bumped into the
you know bumped into his chair by
accident to wake him up a little bit um
which is probably not allowed but it was
a fun tournament it was a more more
relaxed storm but you know it's strange
it very rarely happens there's been a
couple of famous cases but yeah
was the most famous well i know there
was the sochi match with magnus and
anand he had some images of magnus's
falling asleep yeah i mean i remember
that one and i remember anand was just
like looking at this kind of thinking
what's happening here and also happened
to one of my friends but she had a
she had a good old 20 minute map
20 minutes over the board and uh the
arbiters were really unsure whether they
should do something you know because 20
minutes is a long time yeah but uh in
the end you know just when they're about
to build up the courage to wake her up
she kind of woke up like that and
played on plane
all right we do have a few moves here
magnus is now awake luckily
anything happening um nothing too
exciting yes
uh we do have a few moves the strangest
thing from for me is where white has put
his queen and magnus i don't think this
was a master but white's queen now has
completely blocked in the rook in the
corner um so a bit of a strange strategy
there maybe just trying to find a safe
uh square for
um her majesty there the queen just to
kind of create open lines for the other
rook to land on in the center of the
board so a bit of a strange one i've got
to say
i think black should be fine here but
black does have a problem with his
bishops black's bishops lack
kind of scope here they like lack open
diagonals and meanwhile the black queen
also needs to move out the way to
connect the black rooks so very very
symmetrical should be balanced but some
small details yeah sorry dave i was just
saying i thought h6 might be a good idea
because there's this typical plan of
throwing the knight in with the queen
there
to try to get some checkmate ideas and
this this move stops stops all those
ideas at least um yeah but it's a fairly
symmetrical structure isn't it so unless
someone can prove uh their pieces are
better
it should be equal really um when the
pawn structure is symmetrical and yeah i
mean you mentioned they're symmetrical
should be equal and i completely agree
that's why i'm so surprised the
evaluation bar is in magnus carson's
favor
i mean the evaluation bar clearly
doesn't know who the more kind of wide
awake of the two players is but either
way to give white a plus one advantage
it's very surprising when there's not
actually that much direct action
happening
uh maybe we can try to jump into the
position to explore why uh the computer
loves white's position here um we
mentioned this strange position of
white's queen
and simon also mentioned maybe the idea
was it was pointing towards the black
king if black had been careless and just
made a random move then the white knight
might jump forward maybe some hints at
an attack later on but this was stopped
by liam he just pushed the pawn forward
in this position stopping the knight
jumping and now magnus has indeed
planted his rook in the center staring
down at the black queen i'm wondering
just because the evaluation bar jumped
back down is i'm wondering whether white
maybe missed a chance to push his pawn
in the center forward to try and
destabilize black's knight just to try
and kick it away gaining even more space
before black's ready but uh after the
rook did move the black queen now
jumping out of the way as well if black
gets time to centralize the rooks black
is completely fine magnus needs
something quick something aggressive at
this moment before it's too late
yeah and uh yeah some interesting lines
there may be a crucial moment that you
highlighted and well magnus take
instigating some action on the left side
quite quickly you know destabilizing
black's horn center but uh
we do like it you know when the games
are so such fun and we love it when
everyone at home interacts with us and
you can always send us your tweets your
selfies your questions using the hashtag
chesschamps and uh talking about selfies
i have to share with you two awesome
selfies uh one from haydee um jawah who
is actually watching magnus on the plane
to cartagena that's uh pretty cool and
who's good at doing impressions
simon i'll try but i'm rubbish okay but
i don't mind i'll give it a go okay can
you do alan partridge
no
no me knowing you aha me knowing you uh
um
basically anyway i say this because gary
agnew is uh watching our coverage at uh
an allen partridge show
really yeah that's a bit of a waste of a
ticket
is it that bad
that was awesome we're that good yeah
we're great that's the one
yeah i like that one as well so if you
want to send us your selfies please
remember to do it in landscape mode then
uh tweet us using the hashtag
chestchamps and we will try and feature
them on the show definitely please do
use the hashtag chess champs now liam
leo has taken a little bit of a pause
here now sweater out in the lounge is
able to get interviews with the players
as they arrive eric hanson today he is
fighting back after losing tonight geary
yesterday and let's hear what eric said
when he entered the building a few well
what is that 15 minutes ago
day of anti-climax yesterday you played
good chess but you had one move that
kind of defined the math do you take a
good or a poor feeling into the
day-to-day i generally take good
feelings that uh
try to take the good things from those
games and get some sleep and just
oh that's my alarm going off okay um
treat every day you have to remember to
play chess today right exactly no but uh
every day there's a new match a fresh
start so
with a format you can have a bad day and
recover pretty quickly so i'm hoping to
take advantage of that and
and uh do well today still got a good
feeling going into this yeah yeah i mean
the games aren't going to get any easier
but
um i'm building confidence when i like
play like the way i did yesterday
good luck thank you
eric hanson currently playing with the
white pieces against jordan fun for east
and i love to see eric in a great mood
such a good player and great timing a
bunch of moves now coming out they had
the moose flying onto the board here and
uh again it looks like it's maybe going
in magnus's favor uh so what has
happened is that after the tension was
kind of clarified on the left side of
the board pawns just blocking up there
white knight leaped into the middle
instead of going for a trade of knight
which would only have helped white
activate uh the queen
instead liam just blocking things up and
he's trying to use the black knight in
the center of the board just to kind of
stop white's active active plans but
this last move by liam is an offer of a
pawn sacrifice he's allowing magnus to
actually capture the black knight in the
center of the board with white's bishop
white's rook at the bottom as well also
eyeing up that square so white can win a
pawn but it will come at the cost of a
bishop for nitrate and black will then
have the bishop pair so the position
will open up maybe
in black's favor because the bishops
love open lines so big moment now for
magnus is he going to capture the black
knight in the centre of the board with
his bishop
it's quite likely we'll see that so
we'll show it if it does happen but uh
if not then maybe he needs to improve
the white queen and prove that white
rook in the corner of the board because
that one is asleep right now
and uh yeah it looks like magnus at
least is awake
and uh he'll be looking for active ideas
because he does have a small time
advantage he has a healthy position
and uh still the critical moments are
ahead okay
the uh other matches going on we see in
two of them actually the bars have
started moving the bar is liking it for
anish giri against young christophe duda
duda he was quite upset yesterday after
losing to magnus carlsen and apparently
struggling maybe a little bit here in
the game against aneesh gear either game
number one i also see the bar
in the game between eric hanson that we
just heard from anjodin from freeze the
bar slightly over to the dutch
youngster's side he also lost yesterday
fighting for a comeback today we do have
a rook move on the board yeah yeah it
was that transition that i mentioned the
bishop captured the knight and then the
rook backed it up and white is a pawn up
now ivanka what do you think
i was shocked actually i was not
expecting that at all because it kind of
it determines the position suddenly the
position has changed its nature it's a
very dynamic one look at the bishop that
black has and i was expecting magnus to
actually do what he does best which is
just to build improve his pieces and
wait for the tension
to evaporate in a later stage it's not
really like him to grab a pawn like that
i mean uh yeah it's a free pawn but he
he's got to have some pressure against
him now and then it's long-term pressure
as well because black's got the famous
two bishops
and magnus loves those bishops so uh i'm
yeah i'm also surprised that he he's
gone for this i mean what about you
david yeah i mean i you know me and my
bishops as well simon i'm really really
hesitant to ever part with the bishop
even if you can win a pawn in the
process the computer might say plus one
because white is a pawn up but at least
it's much easier for black to play now
and that's why magnus is paused
black's plan is simple black actually
wants to trade off everything which is
not really
intuitive when you're a pawn down but if
black does trade everything off look at
black's light squared bishop is
unchallenged and it's pointing
indirectly towards some of white's pawns
over there on the queen side on the left
side
so if we see a trade of rooks now i'm
not sure what else magnus could be
thinking about maybe he's going to push
a pawn to attack black's queen but there
we go the exchange of rooks did happen
and now magnus has some serious
questions to answer how is he going to
protect his pawns over there
long term and he'd protect his pawns by
retreating his knight from the center so
already
taking steps back it doesn't feel right
for magnus computer still unsure still
thinks white is the one in the driver's
seat but not by much and how will he get
that white rook into the game after sort
of locking it in with his queen yeah he
just needs two moves now he needs to
move the queen out the way again and
then he can bring his rook towards the
center so
right now this was the position a couple
of moves ago i was slightly surprised we
didn't maybe see a pawn push attacking
black's queen but after a train of rooks
and the knight jumping back i'm
expecting magnus now if he's given time
to move his queen forward for example if
black just waits uh to move his queen
forward and then to unleash this rook
this sleeping giant so he needs to bring
it to this square maybe to an open line
and he can team it up with the queen
that being said liam does have a couple
of moves before this plan comes into
action so maybe we could see may the
knight jump to the side of the board at
some point attacking this pawn another
move that comes to mind is maybe the
queen coming forward just to stop that
idea i mentioned if magnus trying to
occupy the open line but then again
magnus could maybe swing his queen
across in a different direction and then
finally unleash this rook so still very
complicated both sides have their ideas
what would you say is most likely right
now simon a win for either of these
players or is this looking a little bit
jewish
i think it's a little bit early to say
um i think it's getting to a very
interesting moment of the game now and
over the next five moves ten moves we'll
have a much clearer picture i mean
magnus is a pawn up so if you can just
stabilize that pawn swap some pieces off
is normally a very very good thing to do
when you're a pawn up
because you want to take out any tactics
if he's able to do that he'll probably
win
but if liam can keep the pressure on and
and keep those pieces on the board then
uh any result is is is possible that old
cliche um
but i i kind of like what liam i think
he's done a great thing here with the
two bishops he looked like he was under
some pressure and offering that
sacrifice was a very clever idea to give
him at least some chances to play for
the win
i think in practical terms it's as you
mentioned simon it's kind of three
results at all possible but it's also
relatively simple
at least
knowing what black wants to trade off
later i think this next couple of moves
are key just to try and contain the
activity of white's pieces
and uh liam just has to make sure he
stays relatively kind of at a decent
amount of time on the clock but also
that he can stop white's queen and rook
entering the game
so he's paused at the right moment he's
uh given up a pawn good decision i think
and now taking that uh time out and i'm
sorry i'm assuming this is magnus's
screen not leopards also i was going to
say it gives magnus a chance to fall
asleep if he has a little break as well
you know have a little rest and sifu you
need to play some um
uh wake me up before you go go what uh
apparently
apparently he's playing a norwegian
super hit song called the
see the fire
light or that was bad translation but
yeah it's a big hit from the 1994
olympics apparently that's what he put
on
1994 olympics is this lillehammer yes
yes
and so and they made this beautiful song
by cecil
can you sing it for us just a little bit
no no no no come on she she's like a
whitney houston kind of singer so you
don't want to hear me saying that i
think we
do yeah
actually i know an interesting fact
about sis or jacob
she is the aunt of two norwegian
actually maybe there's more norwegian um
two norwegian chess girls
really see she's a chess singer yeah the
blood here in norway yeah
very cool so magnus he's uh trying to
get a little bit fired up with uh some
norwegian hit tunes
because he has been a little bit tired
sorry i was just looking at the position
and this this last move surprises me
again
um i mean i think uh this move that liam
played was very clever just moving the
queen as i think david pointed out but
magnus moving his queen into the line of
a rook
it looks odd to me yeah it looks very
odd i guess the idea is the move that i
actually mentioned earlier my first
instinct for white was to move the queen
the whole way actually even next to the
white king but that might have allowed
the black queen to jump into white's
position to jump to the c2 square on the
second rank attacking some stuff
so white here magnus just wants to keep
control of any entry square that the
black queen wants to use but as you
mentioned simon it's so unnatural
queens feel extremely uncomfortable
opposite opponents rooks and
magnus is going to have to waste another
move later putting his queen out of the
eyeline of that black work at the top of
the board so liam it's not clear exactly
what he wants to do now i think magnus
is just trying to frustrate him for the
next couple of moves and then think
about how to improve the position later
on
um very strange move but that's why
magnus is world champion he comes up
with these strange ideas which prevent
the opponents the opponent's plans and
as we've seen consistently actually
magnus never follows the wisdom of the
old greats
he's always breaking the rules you know
playing something that they would not
approve of and here i agree it looks
ugly and it does feel like there is now
is the moment to try to punish this move
but i don't see anything um okay the
queen recentralizes herself
i mean i guess that's an anticipation of
the white rook actually moving itself to
attack the queen on its old on the open
sea line yep and the white knight now in
front of the white queen is pinned it
cannot move out the way because the
black queen will just capture the white
queen
i think it's time for magnus to get out
of the firing line move that white queen
again
maybe the white rook can uh
finally join the action now as well but
okay magnus he needs to be accurate liam
i think he's doing a good job of just
making things difficult
yeah i think so and i was just wondering
about something you said there you've
anchor about magnus breaking the rules
and doing things differently and i'm
just thinking what the ghost of bobby
fischer or the ghost of one of the old
world champions would be thinking if
they saw
the future world champion playing one f3
can you just imagine what fisher would
do i think fisher would approve
about you know a really crazy idea like
get out of there get out of the school
you know it's like yeah you can just
imagine what is this modern day rubbish
you know so i can just you know
weird images grandmasters have been
thrown out of bob vinick's chess school
for much much less than what magnus did
yesterday really f3 and also seeing
magnus fall asleep bob vinnick would be
having some
stern words
with the youngster but isn't it a little
bit interesting if this is some sort of
tactic for magnus to sort of
psychologically put his opponent off
even the sleeping incident and coming in
a little bit late
must put liam liam a little bit you know
off
yeah you mean you would think that i
mean you have to pick your opponents
there's certain people who are very
principled and like come on what are you
doing you know i'm a grand master here
you need to treat this with some respect
but uh you know liam
doesn't give off that vibe as we saw in
the interview with svara and also when i
had a chat with him he just seemed very
calm very happy and uh i think he would
just look at magnus go magnus sleeping
[Laughter]
great for me he's tired
yeah and he is playing a good game
simon also said it you were liking sort
of the road that it was going for the m
yeah definitely i mean i i expect it's
still pretty uh dynamically equal um i
mean just trying to look at some of the
major considerations of the position uh
you can see white has this horrible
backwards pawn which the queen and
bishop are both pointing towards and
this is like the one thing i think black
can really try to uh try to go for
but on the other hand magnus has because
of his extra pawn a very important
square in the center of the board the
center of the board the most important
part of the board as you can control all
areas and that square that david's
highlighted you can put a piece there
and it can never be kicked away because
your porn your extra pawn supports it so
i think they both these two things seem
to me to be the main sort of uh essence
of the position uh so you know going
along that way of thinking
if i was black i'd be looking at moving
my knight to attack the pawn then
naturally white can try defending that
pawn with using both of these concepts
we've talked about and here maybe i can
try to get rid of that knight by uh you
know moving my bishop i know i can't get
rid of it with a pawn but i can try to
exchange it so something like this seems
quite a logical way to continue um in
the position yeah exactly i think this
is what vm is just trying to evaluate
right now these as you mentioned these
moves by black at least they create
threats on every turn therefore they're
very natural they come to the mind first
checks captures and threats and here
there is this threat of taking off the
white knight from the board and then
next move once it's gone capturing this
pawn uh this pawn remember is attacked
three times by black's knight queen and
bishop so uh here there's also pins
along this diagonal uh there's some
calculation to be done that's why liam
is spending so long right now after
knight takes bishop for example he'll be
working out whether maybe he can think
about taking this bishop or whether he
takes this knight if so with it
it's with the black queen whether it's
with the pawn uh but for example at the
very least you could imagine a situation
like this there's still some tension
black's knight's still on a good square
tying down white's army to this pawn and
also this pin on the board so still some
stuff to calculate here that's why liam
is pausing but i expect exactly what
simon's just shown knight to the edge of
the board i think that's the only
logical way to start right now it's
difficult otherwise to improve black's
position and taking under four minutes
now liam lee but a sensible time to
make some calculations and we are
mentioning ivanka's
deep
chest talk with liam it's going to be
launched tomorrow if you head to
chess24.com tomorrow and click on the
collection tab
you'll find that interview with liam i'm
really looking forward to get to know
him a little bit better basically yeah
you know it was incredibly fascinating
to hear his journey because it's not a
story that we hear so often i mean what
is it like you know when i went into the
interview i was like what was it like
growing up playing chess in vietnam
right and
yeah he shed some light into the
difficulties and obstacles that he had
to face
and a series of exchanges and it wasn't
quite what we predicted
the bar's just gone crazy
it was literally like a yo-yo you know
get the yo-yo bar out and swing it i
mean
what was happening there
did they miss something
i'm not sure actually we'll have to i'll
have to backtrack there but it does look
like magnus maybe has just stabilized
the position and we talked about the
advantage of the two bishops as being
black's main compensation for being one
point down the two bishops have
disappeared black traded off a bishop
for a night and this last move by magnus
maybe this is the key maybe uh this is
one that liam missed it's not an obvious
move just parking the white rook behind
a bishop but indirectly it protects that
pawn on the b file and now it's not easy
for him to win his pawn back
yeah maybe there's something even better
for magnus um i just have to take a look
but bar went all the way to the top for
a second i mean i didn't see it but it
could have been i mean this looks like a
very logical as you say david way to
play uh for magnus but i i don't like uh
what liam le cronk has
has done here yeah um in this in this so
far given up bishop and you can see
that he's not winning a pawn back so
yeah it's it's strange it's strange and
now we should mention if black does go
and capture the very strong knight on uh
in the middle of the board the knight on
an outpost if black does trade it with
his bishop white's bishop will recapture
out of the way and then white's rook at
the bottom of the board will protect the
pawn so white is just a clear pawn up
now and
minimal compensation white's still a bit
tied down why it's rook not on the most
active square but
magnus if you're given this type of
advantage in an and now as we edge
towards the end game as well he normally
converts these types of positions and
also the clock times very much
in carson's favor so he's woken up his
position looks good as well and liam
faces an uphill struggle it seems the
the song that i'm used to the song that
magnus put on it really did help and i
just want to
make a little bit of a recommendation to
all of you if you're not already
following mel torture champions chess or
on twitter
champions chess tour is what it's called
on twitter i really recommend you to do
they have for example a post with a
bunch of the playlists that the players
are listening to so you can actually
check out what kind of music they're
listening to and a bunch of moves yeah a
bunch of moves and okay we did mention
bishop takes knight was the most natural
move in the position white's knight was
just too strong it's gone now but after
this trade
uh the black knight jumping back to
defend to attack sorry the white bishop
white has defended it now with this rook
and things are just getting liquidated
getting exchanged getting simplified and
white still got that one extra pawn
that's
likely to decide the game simon do you
think there's any drawing chances here
the evaluation bar not too excited but
to me it looks like white is just a
clear pawn up no
no
no i i mean i think this is going to be
very hard for black it's an extra solid
pawn to to my eyes i mean okay you still
have this weakness we pointed out of the
the the white pawn which is attacked now
by the knight and queen uh which you
know it is is a backwards pawn it is a
weak pawn but um pieces are getting
removed from the board and when you're
pawn up generally uh you know you remove
the pieces you get nearer to converting
so uh i mean i say that okay
clearly it's not game over yet by any
means and black can try to create some
opportunities he moves his queen here to
pin the rook down and there's a bit of
work for magnus to um discombobulate uh
where his pieces are discombobulated
bobbulate is that a word i don't even
know
to
un-discombobulate his pieces yes maybe
it's your favorite word discover
discombobulate
what to say
i have to also agree with you both simon
and david i just think that magnus is in
his element here you know he can just
keep on improving and i love the little
moves that he's just played you know
pushing harry one square give the king a
little bit of air and now look at the
queen and rook he's primed to take the
central d-line
it's just looking great and of course
you've got the bishop as well bishop is
superior over the night in this
particular position there's one tactic
here which maybe is liam's final chance
i think long term if he just does
nothing white will start to improve the
position improve coordinate the bishop
the rook the queen and it's going to be
hard for black to ever hold this
position but if black's rook now comes
down to the bottom of the board
attacking the white queen we would
actually see a trade of rooks so you
distract the white queen away maybe we
can show this or maybe lamp's going to
play it it looks like he's about to make
a move what's it going to be he needs to
move fast one minute now on the clock
but if what if the black comes down to
the bottom of the board white's queen
has to take it and then black's queen
can actually pounce and capture the
white rook so we could see a trade of
rooks in this position and i think this
is what liam has to do bring his rook
down to the bottom of the board deflect
away the white queen see a capture see a
trade and the only chance now i think
for black is to go for this because at
least he will try and win this pawn next
move white has annoying checks but i
think this is his best shot at least
practically i'm sorry for laughing david
but magnus was
deep into some music digging there
okay and he's played it he's played this
move and uh yeah he will he'll need that
rhythm now in the same game he's still
not so easy to win despite what the
evaluation bar says queen takes rook is
about to happen or it has just happened
sorry and queen takes rook i'm expecting
a check here because what else but at
least black has some counterplay against
this pawn yeah i mean at least the queen
and knight are famous for coordinating
extremely well together and you can see
that weak white pawn is actually it's a
serious issue here um so this is to my
eyes at least not so clear now and i
think uh things have improved certainly
for liam uh a little bit here um by by
all standards but how does he guard that
pawn is there well he doesn't need to
guard that pawn he can actually go along
and do his counter-attack so i was
thinking czech okay or and then
maybe something like this yeah yeah yeah
and one other idea that i had was just
attack the knights you know drop the
queen back along the sea line and uh
yeah again
this is critical moment isn't it if he
can find the right way both of these
ideas look quite dangerous i mean does
queen g4 even force the exchange of
queens because if it does that's a very
safe way of playing yeah maybe black can
push this pawn forward but then there
are going to be tactics all the time
against the black king some ideas of
taking this pawn at some point
some kind of pin not right now but at
some point later
pinning this king is a lot to work out
and actually magnus i'm surprised he
allowed this
but uh either way lem fighting really
hard we mentioned before the game his
style is very much kind of a street
fighter he's not always dominating
controlling games sometimes he does but
in general he's always looking for
tactics and ways to transform the
position so
yeah still some
some real life ahead in this game so a
critical moment we're super eager to see
what magnus do critical moments
happening other places in the oslo
esports arena as well
apparently shaktar mamadiro has made a
huge blunder against prague and we see
the bar
loving it for the 16 year old and we can
just see it from his body language there
we saw shaq go oh yeah and uh realizing
maybe there you go
and it just goes to show how resourceful
pragnanda is you know how confident he
is you know he we saw his in him
yesterday in his game against jordan van
forest you know he took some really
gutsy decisions and
now i mean this is great news for
pragnanda because i have to say his
score against shakuriya in previous
events has not been that great
and
well anything can happen of course of
course
i mean they say
there's no luck in chess um maybe
there's not you create your own luck but
he was as you said you rank yesterday he
was losing two games against jordan he
won both of those games and here he was
losing this game he may be winning this
game now and uh he's certainly i want to
know what he's doing because he's
certainly doing something special to
turn the positions around very
resourceful i guess yeah and i just
peeked over at their game just to see
where the mistakes uh were in the game
between prague and mahmoud and it's as
if he just flicked his magic wand and
out of nowhere some crazy tactics
happened he just sacrificed to please
sacrifice another piece and he's winning
so he's down but a big attack for prague
and uh normally actually we see mamajor
of doing that to his opponents normally
he's the one flicking his magic wand and
checkmating them this time prague and
there we go he has won the game wow
first uh game has finished on day two
here in the oslo esports cup pragnanda
the 16 year old he won his match
yesterday getting a great start also now
to day two a win against mamadiarov in
the first game taking the lead in that
match and the question is will magnus
carlsen do the same against liam le and
here we have the answer to that big
decision okay so some very quick moves
we did see a check
and uh the white queen choosing a
different square not one that we
mentioned but also was threatening
checkmate on the last turn teaming up
the queen and bishop and that has been
stopped now by liam so white does have
kind of the safe option at some point of
using the white queen and going back
down to capture black's pawn on the b4
square so magnus has actually found a
very safe way of proceeding
and even if that weak white pawn drops
now white will be a pawn ahead still
very difficult to win queen end games
it's all about past pawns neither side
has a past pawn right now but uh yeah
magnus trying to squeeze out the
advantage liam fighting really hard
yeah i mean that pointed drop i guess if
the queen's come off uh you're really
gonna put magnus as you know nearly 99
favorite so this is why um black's kept
kept the queens on the board he has more
chances to trick magnus and of course we
mentioned the knight and queen worked
very well together um saying that it's a
safe pawn isn't it really now so nothing
to worry about it's what we call a two
result game right yeah i guess so magnus
playing for the win but
even if liam defends perfectly it's only
going to be a draw i think it's going to
take a miracle for liam to win this game
that being said he is creating some
sneaky threats using that black knight
going towards the white king threatening
some checks
and the white king running away to
safety preempting any checks maybe i'm
not sure about that king running away to
safety no i was wondering what you do
against this move wow i mean i missed
that one as well i mean knight a2 and
look at magnus he's shaking his head a
bit is he is did he just miss oh my
words look at it look at that
oh no
and magnus's mouth slips he just gave
away his queen and he's lost
wow oh this is so dramatic what just
happened a huge mouse slip blunder first
and then a mouse slip it just fell apart
for magnus in the space